For a, we'll get this expression. Great work if you got that one correct. We can
do this problem by cross multiplying. So, we'll have negative 7 times 2a minus
3, and 6 times 2a times b. Cross multiplying is really true, though, because
we're multiplying both sides by the least common denominator, negative 42. It
would be the product of these two numbers. We know negative 42 divided by 6
equals negative 7. So we're really left with a negative 7 in our numerator, and
we multiply it by 2a minus 3. Something similar happens on the right, negative
42 divided by negative 7 is 6. So we're left with 12ab. Next we need to
distribute this negative 7 to each of these terms. So we'll have negative 14a,
plus 21 equals 12ab. Remember what we're doing here, we're solving for a, so
let's get this a term over to the right side, so we have two a terms together.
We add 14a to both sides to get this equation. These terms both share an a,
which is what we are solving for. So we factor the a out, leaving us with 12b
times 14. Finally, we divide both sides by this expression to solve for 1a.
These two factors reduce to 1, leaving us with a equals 21 divided by 12b plus
14.